you have these goals and there's all of
these different ways of getting there
and the problem is you're like which one
do I do scenario two is I don't know
what to do to get to there let me tell
you how these feel this one feels like
anxiety if you feel stressed or you are
overwhelmed about which thing you should
do that's this if you don't know what to
do you feel hopeless cuz you're like I
don't know what the to do and it's not
about picking it's like you don't even
know where to start that's what makes me
sad is if I don't know what to do I get
sad so then I can start solving for I
need a path so that I know what to do
I'm like okay I have a lack of choices
so I have a lack of choices means I have
ignorance around this topic this makes
it solvable so whenever I think sadness
I think ignorance it massively
simplifies this very like hard painful
experience it's been really helpful for
me